area is we defined area off few lessons
back remember that the quiet area anyone
remember how we defined it varies ah yes
had to do this space right it's the
space taken up by taking up on what kind
of thing it's gonna be flat isn't it so
I could say the area of this whiteboard
because it's a flat theme okay
so area is the space taken up by I could
say flat but a more mathematical more
specific way to say it is when we are we
have a mathematical way to say when
things are flat with objects a flat
through yeah we talked about their
dimensions right so instead of saying
flat it would be more specific to say
2-dimensional don't really mean it's
flat yeah so area is the space taken up
by a flat object a 2d object okay now
volume is just the same but it's when
you add a third dimension okay
so that area volume on the other hand
okay it's still space taken up by
something the space yeah that's right so
now by the way there's gonna be three
touching here what won't be the
equivalent would it's not flat right
what happens when you've got an object
then it's not flat anymore is it's
three-dimensional
yeah so I'm gonna put that down I think
it's it's solid it's like you know it's
actually got some thickness to it right
so we would say someone on the board
then a solid or three-dimensional
object okay there you go
right now we're gonna have a look at the
volume of a whole bunch of different
chase but just like we haven't really
had yesterday at prisms I can't wait to
carry that idea forward okay so for
prisons now here I'm going to do I'm
gonna try and connect together this area
and this volume idea for prisms volume
is equal to and you can put this next
part in like big letters different color
put it in a box or something like that
okay I'll say V equals okay the area of
the cross section we talked about cross
sections yesterday I'll remind you again
ii what they are after a few trackers
area of the cross section times the
perpendicular height okay let's unpack
this okay what's the cross section
remember these two shapes in these are
some examples all on presumption right
what is a cross section how would you
explain the word the phrase cross
section to somebody who didn't know what
it meant
yes yes sir you cut it in half so i
guess this one didn't be something like
yeah yes okay
slice it saw through it okay go across
it and you get that shape there by the
way it's pay attention we could chop it
in half and that will work but actually
if it's a prism where else could you cut
it
whoa hold on I'm still I still want to
go in the same direction but I can cut
it at different spots I don't have to be
halfway right it's a v8 the key oh yeah
sorry
okay so prisons I do this wonder if you
like so you see that it's another
cross-section and it's still the same
rectangle I could do my mole if I do too
many it's gonna start getting confused
good behavior
they're all the same right if I can work
out the area of that cross-section on
the front okay I have to multiply that
by perpendicular height now I'll admit
this bits a little bit confusing okay
because here if this is the
cross-section that front part that I've
shaded okay the perpendicular height
where is it
it's actually this distance here hmm
that's weird me write that down let's
see if we don't practice why is this the
perpendicular height we had another
measurement before we call it we call
this fire that looks like light it's you
know up down right why would this
actually be important to anyone
throughout nineteen why might we choose
that is coming ahead and not not this
one
okay so the first thing is you know in
some sense I can be anything right
because I can just like moving around
right
he's shape when I hold it like this this
looks like the height right but if I
turn it over so well this is the height
now looks like I can kind of be anything
right
why did I choose this I didn't choose
any other yeah for this diagram yes but
I'll talk about why I chose that in a
second more jackets for okay sure at
least in this case Howard water that is
the longest okay but like I said let me
come back to this right at the moment
this is the longest okay that's but I
still couldn't turn it over and I could
get a different height so why do I
choose that now the key is all in this
work here perpendicular why is that
important
ah okay so this is a really crucial idea
and maybe we might even write this
underneath because it's so important
okay
the perpendicular height this is how you
can know what the perpendicular height
is okay
it's thought it's the length or the
height or the breath or whatever that's
perpendicular to the cross section
we said that again that's really
important the perpendicular height we
call a burr perpendicular height and not
just height it's perpendicular hikers
perpendicular to the cross section so
these two cross section and puffing
behind they're kind of two halves of
three sides of the same coin but they go
together right so this is my cross
section I can't call this book up in
detail or higher because it's not
perpendicular to that face okay Ellie
this one is you see that so the
perpendicular height is I think I could
save the dimension all length or fine
does matter that is perpendicular to
yes okay so perpendicular let me get
this again and hopefully it'll help
perpendicular means at right angles
doesn't it makes a nine degrees so for
instance let's choose and I can you
actually have a whole bunch of choices
here right I've got six faces you choose
one and we'll make that one the
cross-section which one do you like this
one okay so this looks like they're sort
of the fattest one I suppose
okay so this is the the cross-section
okay he's the way I work it out I'm
gonna put the cross-section flat on the
ground okay for cross-sections on the
ground okay now what direction is
perpendicular so that part is flat on
the ground
okay it's gonna be going up think about
it like a flagpole if I put a flag pole
here right a flagpole is perpendicular
to the ground heading straight out of
the ground do you look at it it's at 90
degrees to the ground if I drew an angle
there that's a this is I shouldn't
bother bears before
that's a main degree angle there can you
see it okay so it's something particular
okay I'll use this in a second okay so
therefore if you chose this as the cross
section put it on the ground okay and
then look up so we chose this is the
cross section yeah so imagine putting
that part on the ground and that's why
when you look up you go in that way okay
so choosing the perpendicular height is
really important and it's tricky yeah
okay so what did I choose as the cross
section I've chosen this side here right
so if I put that side on the ground so
actually it sort of looks like this
doesn't it that's pretty close isn't it
so I've chosen this as the cross section
there you go right so I'm gonna put that
part on the ground
so now what's up ups that way
that's this tall this tall plant here
okay now for this we could choose right
but if you have a look at this
triangular prism now right you don't
have so much choice
where's the cross technique I just
which one's the cross-section there have
to be the triangle on the front right so
yes that make sense coos yeah that's
right because if I cut it if I cut it
lots of times
I'll just get another triangle see that
so that's what makes it the same shape
always right okay so which way is the
height then I'll actually say the
perpendicular height which way does it
go yeah wait say it again
the longest one right it's the longest
one so he's the ground so you're going
up that way in fact it's just like this
one isn't it there's the UM I should go
all the way there is the perpendicular
height okay so yeah I think it's helpful
and I think that's kind of why we call
it the perpendicular height and not just
height right so that you know which one
is now if you work out what the area
cross section is and you can you can
work that out you multiply the
perpendicular height that'll give you
your volume so let's quickly look at an
example and then I can start talking
this is now you can go to page 218
okay I'll wait I wanted to say one more
thing
here we go need this guy okay now so far
right we'll be looking at nice sort of
modern shapes rectangles but actually
doesn't matter what the shape is so long
as you can work out the cross-sections
so example here we go
I mean sorry okay he go now this shape
here right that I've just created is it
still the prism what do you think we
reckons it still is you reckon is still
prism I think it is - a prism how can
you tell
go back to you how do we define what a
prism is let's do to make sure about
small other paths right it's got faces
but there's more than that like if I if
I took off this for example I do this
it's not a prism anymore so so why is
this important okay so go back go back
to yesterday right what makes it Friesen
a prism is you can cut it for example
like this okay and when you when you saw
through it and that shape is the same
what's backwards there we go you see
that right so cross-section is the same
all the way through the shame okay so if
you want to look at the volume it's the
same you work at the area of the
cross-section you multiplied by the
perpendicular for example I mean if it
was all if each block was one unit
what's the area of the cross-section is
it big enough that you can see it's
seven right one two three four five six
seven seven
now how tall is this thing again not a
rhetorical question
you see it's it's five isn't it right so
it's gonna be seven times five thirty
five which I suppose if I cannot every
individual block that's what I would get
okay so so long as you can work out the
area of the cross-section you're flying
in fast sometimes
have a look for example were on page 218
if you question three right have a look
at question three with me they just tell
you what the area of the cross-section
is can you see if there is a question if
it's some leader looking shape like that
oh yeah okay you mean you mean like this
like if I talk about this scenario yep
in that case number one it won't be a
prison right
so then number two you don't do it so
what we'd have to do I suppose and this
is for later on right
I guess what you have to do is break it
up into some kinds of shapes that you
can't work out for instance now I've got
two prisms and I can work out each one
independently okay so that's how I would
approach that kind of question but those
are the ones you get today